we had a little thing that we said in
tasking a Bruiser it initially it came
from Tony fratty BTF
Tony he said it probably a few times and
then it kind of caught on with me for
sure as just a good thing to
say it's a good thing to have in your
back pocket is basically when when
somebody would start talking about
why something was going to be hard or
why it wouldn't work or how complicated
it was or what was going to make
something so
difficult what we'd say is we don't care
about any of
that we don't care about any of
that which is an which is an awesome
saying people get so focused on why
things won't
work and what might go wrong
and if you're not careful those things
can really they can really trip you
up and you can start to
wonder if your plan is even
feasible or you might get overly
concerned with some possible
contingencies and you can start to
overthink and over complicate
things or you can just say I don't care
about any of
that I don't care about any of that now
look am am I telling you to be
careless no I'm not telling you to be
careless am I telling you not to
consider possibilities and difficulties
that might arise no I'm not telling you
that either am I telling you not to
think through what you're going to do
and how you're going to do it no I'm not
saying
that but I am saying that
sometimes especially with like little
things little lowrisk things that people
are sweating the details on like
like what workout of the day will
produce Optimum results or what heart
rate is best for my cardio development
or when will you be able to get the best
deal on that piece of gear that you need
or where should we go for dinner
tonight or when's the most favorable
time to get started or what's the most
advant advantageous way to do
whatever lots of questions you can ask
yourself and some times it's a good
option just to say I don't care about
any of
that and go execute